foreign
[Music]
everyone is very tired
i can see them
um
firstly i'd like to uh
just
thank everyone for coming here
especially alexa and society for
inviting me here
to give this talk
this is going to be a very heavy subject
for this evening especially given that
you're having your midterms at the
moment
and
as i'm familiar with
much of muslim culture on this side of
the world
this is not one of your favorite
subjects to talk about
had it been about marriage i'm sure this
whole place would have been full by now
or maybe about jin or something of that
sort which is why i am grateful to
al-aqsa from society because they are
actually bringing up the issues that are
most important to this
in the contemporary period
there's only so many lectures you can
have on marriage
to realize that that's not our problem
um and that's not to say that these
subjects aren't important
but our in-laws should be about
being balanced it should be about
addressing every issue that's what islam
is about and when we focus on domestic
issues only
we have a serious problem
either in the sense that we lack the
intellectual clout to deal with it
or
it's too controversial
uh recently i put up a post on my
facebook uh regarding ada
and how many people misconceive
what this
aspect of our religion is
and many people find it to be simply
about our mannerisms and simply about
how not to have conflict with others
however it's more than that it's about
behaving in a way that we bring justice
to everything in our lives
we bring justice and balance to
everything in our lives and every
obstacle that we face
and in that regard when we face with
issues such as terrorism and extreme
extremism in the contemporary period
this is something that we should be
firmly
geared towards resolving
to the best of our abilities not only as
a community but as intellectuals as
brothers and sisters
of the same faith
so i'd like to thank you once again for
bringing this controversial topic to the
stage
and for possibly putting a target on my
back
which is fine
now uh before we get into the
subject any further just a minor
disclaimer
um
as a brother had suggested uh stated
about me earlier uh my degrees are in
philosophy so i just i actually studied
western philosophy for about six years
of my life
i'm very tired as you can see
um i then studied islamic philosophy
and now i decided to do something more
practical with my life and
apply my analytical thinking skills to a
more
extreme subject as you can see
and my
thesis is on isis
so i will be discussing them at length
as well
throughout this lecture i hear there may
be some supporters in the university so
if you wish to kill me please do so
afterwards so that i can finish my talk
i'd be greatly appreciated
i'd also like to thank
my parents and my wife for allowing me
to
give this talk
given my safety concerns involved
and uh and for still encouraging me to
talk about these important issues so i
believe i've wasted five minutes
of my time enough and let's jump
straight into the conversation all right
then uh now i promise that i won't be
too boring because the subject is not
exactly fine
it can be a little bit dreary
uh however uh there's a lot of
information that has to be had here and
um i think a lot of things that have not
been told to you because western media
in general tends to frame the subject in
such a way that we cannot fully
understand why
muslims
will go out and kill themselves or kill
innocent people we honestly still don't
have the answers as to why because
the western notion of terrorism is so
corrupt
that it disallows us from actually
understanding what's going on
and i hope to in this lecture to
elucidate or to explain
what the actual factors are behind this
violence
and what islam has to say about it
all right so the definition of terrorism
needs to be explained first before going
any further
and the general definition that has been
accepted by most academics is the
following
the unlawful use of force and violence
against persons or property to
intimidate or coerce a government the
civilian population or any segment
thereof
in furtherance of political or social
objectives basically
force or coercion against a civilian
population
primarily
or government unlawfully without being
provoked
for the purpose of gaining some sort of
political
or social
goal or gain
this definition however
is disputed
as the west itself is the one who has
defined it
and if we look at the history of
western warfare this definition has
often been
violated on numerous occasions such as
the bombings of dresden during world war
ii when the allied powers had carpet
bomb german cities of civilians trying
to force them to oppose hitler
killing thousands and thousands of
innocent men women and children
however that was never
recorded as a war crime
the bombings of nagasaki hiroshima
that killed over 300 000 people in the
immediate blast and then 50 years of
constant
radiation damage
to the local population killing another
hundred thousand or more
that is not talked about as a war crime
i'm sure the japanese feel otherwise
even recently in iraq during the iraq
invasion the second one
george bush jr sent his forces in
and attacked the city of fallujah
[Music]
using iranian tip bullets to this day
is considered
a more horrible offense
than even the aftermath of nagasaki
hiroshima more mutations to this day are
still
damaging the population
of those children
but the west doesn't call it terrorism
and there's a reason for that which
we'll get into
[Music]
in the near future
so i propose that this definition
is not a universal one
rather
the proper definition of terrorism from
the western perspective is this
the unlawful use of force and violence
by muslims
against persons or property to
intimidate or coerce a government the
civilian population or any segment
thereof in furtherance of political or
social objectives
catch the addition that i made
the unlawful use of force and violence
by muslims
now this may seem a little unfair a
little bit straw manning my opposition
but we will see soon enough that this is
actually the case and this is actually
how policies are constructed in the west
in regards to terrorism and violence
prior to that however i think that would
be appropriate to discuss what islam's
position is on terrorism and what it
defines as terrorism from our tradition
[Music]
so
terrorism is often associated with jihad
in the media
however jihad from the islamic
perspective as we are all fairly aware
of is simply to struggle or to strive
against obstacles that prevent us from
getting closer to allah or deprive us of
our general well-being
this would be i think an appropriate
definition
for the concept that you have that also
covers not only the external struggles
that we deal with on a daily basis
not even the extremes such as warfare
but also the inner struggles
the various and often spiritual battles
that we face in order to come closer to
allah on a daily basis
however
jihad has been
misconstrued as simply being a physical
conflict but from our tradition
jihad from the physical sense is
actually the least considered it is the
least practiced
in our religion
in fact another form of jihad is
considered much higher and no i'm not
going to
give the opinion that
the energy hot is the greater god in
fact this is
based on a weak hadith weak narration
though that it is to some extent that is
actually not the greater jihad according
to our sources
the quran elucidates give us a clue as
to what the greater jihad actually is
sort of 25 52 the quran states
obey not the unbelievers and the
hypocrites and strive against them
in a mighty way in a great way with
the quran
with the quran
now unless you think you're going to be
throwing the quran people then i don't
think that's it doesn't mean physical
okay it means obviously
in oral fashion
all
is to say a word of truth before a titan
the best jihad
is to say a word of truth
before a tyrant
today we have many people saying that
the only way you can become
or you can join the jihad is by making
hijrah over to a war zone and fighting
but the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was already
practicing jihad the moment he began his
mission
according to this narration
according to this he was already
practicing jihad the moment he opened
his mouth
to express the revelation
to his community
he was in the head
way before the battle of mother
and this is
further exemplified by the fact that
even
and the tongue
takes precedence over jihad with the
sword and the spirit
once again
jihad with decisive proof
and the tongue takes precedence
precedence meaning what
it is above it is first
exemplar
over jihad with the sword and the spirit
this is also further evidence
by the first martial in islam
[Music]
how did she pass away did she pick up a
sphere of a sword
and march into battle and then she was
declared a martyr
she was persecuted for what she spoke
and she was killed on account of that
she became a martyr
for the jihad that came from here
not from her soul not from her spirit
and she was the first among all of us
[Music]
and unfortunately we have sort of
downgraded this understanding of jihad
we have we have somewhat
made
we have given into the misconceptions
that jihad is simply about physical
warfare
especially in regards to how we did tawa
you hear many days today and i'm not
going to name anyone but you're going to
hear many guys today who say that
we should not argue with people we
should not debate with people we should
always be softly spoken we should always
be nice to them we should always you
know kumbaya
and you know sitting there and eating
popcorn marshmallows i don't know if you
like the combination i happen to
right
but this is not the case actually this
is not the case well the prophet saws
did give us
guidance etiquettes to follow when we do
debating and when we
when we engage with the enemy as
you may call them okay of course we're
not supposed to be vulgar
but he did not say
and the quran especially did not say
that you should be
uh
so tolerant that you're not
controversial that you're not
confronting
so for instance in the quran
sort of 29 46
and do not argue with the people of the
book except in a way that is best
except for those who commit injustice
among them
among them this only counts for those
who are not committing injustice
you're speaking the best matter to them
you are not harsh with them but if they
are somebody who is
fit in my life beyond
this does not
apply
another place the quran 66 9 states oh
prophets all of a sudden strive against
the disbelievers and the hypocrites and
be harsh with them
hell
will be their home
be harsh with them once again this does
not mean vulgarness doesn't mean that we
go around insulting them
but it also doesn't mean that we give in
to their demands we do not give in to
their standards
we come back there
sternly
we try to establish truth
as strongly as we possibly can and we do
not give up
and for most of the prophet saws life
this was the form of jihad that he
practiced in fact he actually went to
very few battles
many of you are aware of this he rarely
fought actually compared to
how much he spoke how much he debated
with the buffalo he rarely went about it
rarely
and yet we have so many
muslims these days
claiming that
somehow this was the brunt of his
mission this was somehow how islam was
spread primarily we actually have
individuals who are saying this now i'm
not saying that islam is also just peace
because that's also false
islam is not peace islam is not war
islam is submission islam is balance
islam calls to wasathia it doesn't call
to pacifism it isn't called to allah war
but for some reason the muslims in this
day and age we take two extremes we
either say no it's all peaceful and dubs
and bunnies and everything else
and you have another group that says no
it's all bloodshed
and death and destruction
all of these are wrong
because in this day and age it's hard to
be balanced
it's easier to be lazy than just pick
and explore
much easier
so what about jihad of the sword
not only is this the least practiced
but
there are so many limitations to it
that to even claim that it's comparable
to modern warfare
is an insult
not only to the teachings itself but
even
to
basic intellect in regards to how modern
warfare is practiced
the quran once again says to 190 fight
in the way of allah those who fight you
but do not transgress the limits indeed
allah does not like transgressors what
are these limits
there are many do not kill
non-combatants primarily men women
children who are not in warfare do not
kill the elderly do not kill the
disabled
do not kill monks do not kill anyone
that is not a threat to you do not chomp
down a tree do not kill animals for no
reason do not steal
do not cause economic disharmony by
putting sanctions on other governments
and killing 500 000 children like you
did in iraq
do not starve the populations do not
drain them of their water supply do not
pollute them
there are so many conditions here it
would almost seem impossible from the
modern mindset
that you could win a war
because you can't break any of these
rooms
do not
consume the enemy with fire
and yet we drop bombs on everyone
it's interesting
how today we don't have much of a
discussion on the use of certain weapons
how many scholars have discussed the use
of bombs i'm not talking about suicide
but i'm talking about dropping from
hundreds of feet in the air
has anybody ever discussed
uh there have been discussions by the
way very rarely
how many people have discussed
this form of warfare
do you know that over 80 percent of
casualties in modern warfare in the past
100 years have been civilians
over 80 percent of all deaths from war
are civilians
why
because of our technology
there is no such thing as a precision
bomb
the moment a bomb drops
to kill its target it's going to kill
100 times more people around that person
would have nothing to do with
it this is expected
and this is the standard of modern
warfare
where are our scholars saying bombs
should not even be allowed to begin with
now of course we have instances in war
where mortars were used and such but
they did not explode upon impact
they broke down walls they may have
crushed some people but they did not
explode and send shards and shrapnel
hundreds of feet into the air killing
men women and children in nearby
buildings
have we discussed these weapons why do
all muslim nations
have
these this technology
when they know it's going to kill more
civilians than it is going to solve then
it's going to kill soldiers
collateral damage even is not really a
concept in islam
we have it but for very extreme
situations and i mean extreme
as it may never happen
for instance if you know
that there is a building with a group of
soldiers
and there are more civilians or equal
amount to those soldiers within that
building you are not allowed to hit it
that is it
there is no collateral damage in that
sense that you are not allowed to target
that building to kill those people you
either take the damage from those
soldiers or you find another way to
attack them but you will not kill those
people inside of you
that is a rule of thumb for us
this is not debatable
of course there are different opinions
that you have but they will never go to
the extreme that some of the modern
so-called
going around healing people
[Music]
it doesn't go to that extreme those
opinions
so in islam
[Music]
terrorism would probably be best
and terror says
and we understand this from
[Music]
one place in the quran
532-34
and i'm going to read the entire i need
you to understand the context here we
are ordained for the children of israel
that if anyone killed a person not
retaliation of murder or and just
spreading mischief in the land it would
be as if he killed all of mankind and if
anyone saved a life it would be as if he
saved all of mankind
and indeed
there came to them our messengers with
clear proofs evidences and signs however
even after that many of them continue to
exceed the limits by doing oppression
unjustly and exceedingly unlimited
sufficient law
such as major sins
in the land
indeed the penalty for those who wage
war against allah and his messenger they
are connected
if you commit corruption
you are waging war against allah and his
messenger
and strive upon us to cause corruption
is none but that they be killed or
crucified or that their hands and feet
be cut off from opposite sides or that
they be exiled from the land
that is for them a disgrace in this
world and for them and thereafter is a
great punishment except for those who
return repenting before you actually
hang them
and know that allah is forgiving and
merciful
now in regards
people
a lot of the classical scholars will
state that
this only refers to beginning basically
people who
wait on the side of the road and they
they kill incoming
traders and steal their property and
their money okay however it has been
extended throughout time as new
situations were revealed so for instance
once again another disclaimer here i'll
be using
andalusian scholars not because i'm a
nationalist
but because um i study primarily
malekith
and most of their scholars in history
are from andalusia so if i mention a lot
of andalusians it's not because i'm
mentally scenes just because that
happens to be the case
so uh
anyways if it has some states
one who puts people in fear on the road
whether or not with a weapon at night or
day in urban areas or in open spaces
in the palace or of a caliph or a mosque
with or without accomplices in the
desert or in the village in a large or
small city etc etc making people fear
that they'll be killed
or have their money taken or be raped
by the way he's one of the first
scholars to include rape
into this definition
and when he was asked why he said
taking the dignity away from a woman is
worse than taking her money
that was his response
he said when any person commits this
crime and causes terror fear among the
population
he is therefore liable to the punishment
the maliki jurors
define the agent of
the terrorist as anyone who disturbs
free passage in the streets
we'll switch to the microphone no one
can hear me
it's very discouraging
so i have been talking randomly
can hear anything i say okay well
uh thank you
[Music]
anyone who deserves free passages i'm
afraid i'm gonna blow your ears out
that's why i'm not doing it close
uh by taking money killing people or
violating what god has made unlawful to
violate is guilty of
be a muslim or a non-muslim free or
slave and whether he actually realizes
his goal of taking money or killing or
not so even if he's a terrorist who
doesn't know what he's doing
he's still guilty of that crime
many contemporary scholars echo this
view
however
if islam is very clear about limitations
and very clear about what terrorism is
okay that you cannot cause terrorism
can't hurt innocent people you can't
cause discord and corruption within
society
why is it that there are so many muslims
i would say so many but a sizable
minority
that is suggesting otherwise
well let me give you the poster boy for
these individuals the late osama bin
laden
after the attacks of 9 11 in october
21st
he had an interview with al jazeera
where he says this
they
say that the killing of innocents is
wrong and invalid and for proof they say
that the prophet's son forbade the
killing of children and women and this
is true he admits this is true we can't
kill women children we can't kill
innocent people osama bin laden is
saying this okay
he goes on though
it is valid and has been laid down by
the prophet saws in an authentic
tradition
but this forbidding of killing children
and innocence is not absolute
let me repeat that
and i will continue with this quote
osama bin laden said that this
prohibition is not
absolute it goes on
if the disbelievers were to kill our
children and women then we should not
feel ashamed to do the same
to them
may need to deter them from trying to
kill our children and women again
the scholars and the people of knowledge
such as
in his tafsir
say that if the disbelievers were to
kill our women and children then we
should not feel ashamed to do the same
this is osama bin laden saying that this
is not set in stone this is not you can
violate this rule
this is osama bin laden saying this
and he tries to quote
him
now this is interesting that he that he
actually references him unfortunately
because his tafsir doesn't actually say
that it says the complete opposite which
shows you how ignorant osama bin laden
actually was
this is what imam kirk to be actually
said and i quote in this tough season
it is not permissible for us to
retaliate in the same manner
even if they kill our women and children
and cause sorrow to befall us
it is not permissible for us to act
likewise with the intention of making
them feel grief and sorrow and terror
the very people he's referencing
contradict him
[Music]
but why did osama bin laden say this did
he have any scriptural support other
than these scholars that he thinks
supported him
he thinks he does
osama bin laden and al-qaeda and all
these other groups who follow them
okay they use particularly two
eyes in the quran
to back their justification for killing
civilians in the west
the first of them is in
fighting in the sacred month is for
aggression committed in the sacred month
and for all violations is legal
retribution
so whoever has assaulted you
then assault him in the same way that he
has assaulted you
this is the first one so they're saying
if the enemy has attacked you a certain
way you can attack them in the same way
all right
the next one 16-126 and if you punish an
enemy punish with an equivalent of that
which you have been harmed
these are the two
main passages they refer to
in order to attack civilians in the west
okay or anywhere else where they
feel
disenfranchised
however
there is a major problem with their
understanding of these two items
it's a major problem
and for that since i think
we have some time i'm going to need some
volunteers
to help me
so if four
young gentlemen would like to walk up to
the stage right now they'll be greatly
appreciated
please
i would like to show you how this logic
doesn't make any sense and at the same
time
i want you i need two more people
two more brothers
don't be shy i'm not going to hurt you
much
i need two more people please i i have
to have
[Music]
today you're going to be actors
and if you do well enough you might get
a nomination
beautiful brothers
fight in the way of allah those who
fight you but do not transgress limits
indeed allah does not like transgressors
here's where i don't even i don't have
to give you
to show you how ridiculous this
interpretation is i'll show you right
now okay i'm going to give you a story
can i use this one
oh that's great it's like i'm on a game
show
okay
so
we're going to have person a and person
b and their families okay so this is
going to be a small story to represent
the contemporary world
so you're going to be mr west
okay mr not kanye west
mr
[Music]
you're going to be mr east okay
and you're going to be his family all
right
now
one day
mr west decides he's feeling
particularly superior
that day and he wants to
make mr east
eat the same food as him
this is a very basic example okay so you
want to make sure that mr east only eats
mcdonald's the rest of his life all
right
now mr east you love rihanna
and you are not going to allow somebody
to come over and make you eat mcdonald's
now you decide that you have some
weapons
and you don't like mr east anymore
and you're going to kill mr east
nobody's smiling please
and no throwing over
[Music]
okay
so
[Music]
mr east
if you kill him directly it'll cause
some problems
so you're going to kill his family
instead
okay
so
just shoot him or something boom okay
now you're going to be dead
now
you've killed his family now mr east is
very angry
okay
you killed my family
and
as far as i'm concerned the quran says
that if you do something to me i can do
the same to you
so instead of killing mr west
it kills his family
wow
with that uh he's gonna get one faster
than uh leonardo dicaprio
so
um
okay so first question to the audience
this is an interactive session
first question to the audience
did mr west in mysteries did their
families do anything wrong
they did nothing wrong
okay good
now
who is
mr west
right
now
who is the retaliator
all right
now here's the problem
not only did the families not do
anything
but the aggressors have not been
punished
how have they not been punished
because the people who were aggressed
against were not them
it was their families
you understand
the logic here they are only partially
victims the main victims
were their families
so the people who should technically be
retaliating
are their families
not them
does that make sense
are you following the logic again
okay i'll make it more clear for you
when he was attacked
all right it was not him that was
attacked it was his family
okay
so when he if he is going to tell you on
behalf of this family he needs to hit
the aggressor that attacked his family
which should be him
not him
does that make sense the families were
not the aggressors in any situation so
they have no right to be punished
this is why this logic does not work
because
the people who are using these idols are
confusing who the punisher is and who
the punisher is
they're actually very egotistical
because they're saying i was punished
because my family was killed
that is the most egotistical thing you
could say it is not you who was punished
it was your family your family is dead
not you
you were suffering as a result of that
but you were not the victim your family
was the victim
they have a right upon the aggressor for
him to be killed as a result of that not
his family
when this man
not saying you're gonna do it but when
this man kills his family
he has become exactly like his enemy
you understand
that is what do not transgress limits
means when your tough seer of the quran
is your enemy
you have no limits
you have zero
limits
the manhattan of these people
who claim to be on the sunnah who claim
to be following the quran
and you may live again
thank you for the lovely demonstration
gentlemen
[Music]
um
so i wanted to make that point
uh we don't have any time left uh so
then we're going to
reserve the rest for the next session
um
and that's actually pretty good because
i have a lot more information
but i hope that you all understand this
point
um and to close this part off i want to
mention once again that
just because the enemy has done
something to you even if they've done it
to you
our religion is very explicit about the
limitations and about the boundaries in
which we are allowed to fight them back
because once again if we define our
reaction based on our enemies behavior
we are not following our religion we're
following theirs
does that make sense
this is why this ayah cannot be
interpreted in such an expansive manner
because by the time that we have
interpreted in this matter if we
continue to interpret it in this manner
we are leaving our religion and joining
the enemies
we are becoming exactly what we are
fighting
[Music]
and this is just one of the major proofs
as to how these people are completely
ignorant i did not even have to provide
much to you i just had to show you the
logic of what eye for an eye actually
means i just had to show you that these
people were victims they were not the
the perpetrators that's all i had to
show you
and that simple understanding that you
easily grasp cannot be grasped by these
so-called
so
thank you very much for that
demonstration
uh inshallah uh the next session i think
will be more revealing
we just went through some basics
but i will be exploring the ideology
that actually
makes them want to do these things and
i've already given you a hint
but i'm going to get a little bit more
detailed in the next session and i'll be
discussing
contemporary events such as the
syrian revolution
including the rise of isis
in the past three years so that'll be
more exciting for you guys and uh please
take a break
um i hear that the audio is bothering
people so i'm going to try to speak
louder and more clearly into the
microphone
i apologize for those who have not been
able to hear inshallah
you still have benefited from the last
session
however this part of the session i think
will be
even more beneficial because this is
where i'm going to reveal to you
the ideology that actually perpetuates
or
motivates
terrorism
[Music]
uh and first i want to
give you an idea of how the west views
islam i think you all know this army
especially from the video that you just
saw
islam
is seen as a violent religion that wants
to impose itself onto the rest of the
world
okay
now we all know this is absurd
this is a ridiculous belief however it
is taken very seriously in the west and
especially western media
in fact the notion
is that terrorism is caused
by religiously devout individuals people
who are too islamic
that is why terrorists exist because
they are being
too islamic they are following the
prophet's islam too much
they are following the quran too much
that is why they are committing
terrorism
that is what is being told to us
and that is what is motivating
the policies
in the west
against the muslim world
however
there have been some recent studies
by western researchers
who are now starting to wake up and
realize that there is something wrong
with this narrative
[Music]
all of these individuals that i'm about
to name all of these organizations that
i'm about to name are not muslim
yet for the past few years they have
been studying
the data
they have been interviewing all these
terrorists they have been looking into
their lives and they realized a very
common thread
that goes through all of them
and this may startle you
but i think that you need to know
the most recent study in 2015 by
professor harun kunani who is an atheist
former hindu
studying in the united states
he wrote a
paper called in a decade lost
and he states therein and i quote
the factors which lead someone to commit
acts of terrorism are complex and cannot
be reduced to holding a set of values
deemed to be radical
there is little evidence to support the
view that there is a single cause to
terrorism and this is after he had
researched all the contemporary research
on terrorism he says that there is no
evidence whatsoever
that individuals would become more
devout to islam
perpetuate violence and terrorism there
is no evidence
john horgan an expert on terrorism and
radicalization at pennsylvania
pennsylvania state university united
states
says that the idea that radicalization
causes terrorism
is perhaps the greatest myth
alive today in terrorism research
first
it has been proven that the overwhelming
majority of people who hold radical
beliefs do not engage in violence what
does he mean by radical beliefs
he defines them
if you want a childhood
okay if you want to implement sharia
if you want to implement
uh you know even the vimy the dimmi laws
for from the ottoman empire these
individuals are the least likely to
commit acts of terrorism
interesting
he goes on to say secondly there is
increasing evidence
that people who engage in terrorism
don't hold radical beliefs they are more
secular
they are far more secular
mark sageman another radicalization and
terrorism expert suggests that
government should stop being brainwashed
by this notion that radicalization
causes terrorism
mi5 the equivalent of the cia in britain
i'm sure all of you have heard of mi5
okay
states that all of the people they've
investigated are charges of terrorism
this is about two or three hundred or so
were religious novices religious novices
what does that mean
they lack religious literacy and they do
not practice their faith
these are kuffar talking about
so-called muslim terrorists
they say they don't practice their
religion
moving on
arizona state university 2015 as well or
is it 2014. uh they examined over 2 000
texts of so-called islamic extremists so
basically
letters and things like this from osama
bin laden
and all these groups they were you know
sending back and forth to each other
they sometimes would put quran and
hadith of course in their letters to
encourage each other okay
they found that
of all the ayahs that were quoted from
the quran okay
only reference self-defense
and humiliation
none of them were about aggressive
warfare
none
all of it was about self-defense
they felt like they were being attacked
and alienation okay
so it's not because the religion tells
them to go on jihad and you know kill
people just because they felt like they
were defending themselves that was their
main
reason to include certain eyes of the
quran
recent studies even revealed
that a sizable portion of some of the
foreign fighters who enter who join isis
who come from britain and sweden and
other places okay
they like to shop on amazon.com
all right because you know before you go
on jihad you want to do some reading
and uh
they found that the majority of text
that they purchased was not the quran
and the collections of a hadith okay the
majority of books that they purchased
and i kid you not this is from several
people was islam for dummies
and the quran for dummies
i'm not joking okay
now if you don't believe me here are
some recent examples of these so-called
islamic extremists all right let me give
you some examples
okay
the recent isis
shooter on the tunisian beach that
killed uh 38 people with an ak-47 anyone
remember that
that was in 2015. okay very recent
he went on tunisian beach he held an
ak-47 in his umbrella he went in the
water he waited and nobody was paying
any attention took it out just started
shooting everyone on the beach
he killed 38 people until he was gunned
down
okay
when they did an autopsy on him oh by
the way isis took uh credit for the
attack
when they did an autopsy on him they
found out he was drugged on cocaine
he was high on cocaine and he was a
cocaine drug dealer
that's just one i have several more
two of the paris attackers the recent
paris attack that killed 130 people
four weeks prior to the attack two of
the brothers who were involved in the
attack the major actors of his tech the
suicide bombers
they sold their bar
their pub
before they committed the attacks they
sold their pub they were selling alcohol
and narcotics
before they
decided to kill these people
does that sound like
a devout muslim
to you
let me continue
the charlie hebdo attackers people who
went to charlie hebdo and killed the
french
the uh cartoonist okay
they frequently smoked marijuana
hashish and were involved in petty
crimes and drug trafficking
so we're the boston marathon bombers
okay
we can do this all day we go all the way
back to the 911 attackers whether you
regard that as being conspiracy or not
i'm not going to get into that we can do
that in the q a if you wish but for
right now the individuals that we're
talking about who were accused
okay
several of them were found in the strip
club a week before the attacks
drinking alcohol and stored in cocaine
these are the the the people who want to
be like
the prophet muhammad these are the
people bringing back the khilafah
they're drug dealers
and people who don't practice their
faith
at all
many of the 9 11 attackers
they found that before they killed
themselves they found several of their
notes in their private dormitories and
things
where they had made deals with al-qaeda
and others
offering them large sums of money to pay
off their debts and the family debts
and they say that that was their main
motivation it wasn't because they felt
oh now i'm all pious and i'm going to
fly you know slam a plane into a
building
is because they were being paid off
[Music]
now
if we are to show that the majority of
these terrorist attacks are being
perpetuated or being
conducted by people who are not even
practicing
is there any other evidence that we can
show that being a devout muslim
doesn't make you a terrorist in fact
there is
it's quite a bit i'm going to give you
two studies because
uh
these are the most important ones that
have been released in the past year okay
the first one is by professors professor
stephen fish from uc berkeley united
states all right
he studied the murder rates in muslim
majority societies for the past 20 to 30
years
he found the following and i quote
predominantly muslim countries only
average 2.4 murders per annum per 100
000 people meaning there's two point
there's two and a half murders for every
hundred thousand people in a muslim
society okay
all muslim societies
however
in non-muslim countries it's 7.5 to
every 100 000
that's triple
the amount of murder rates in non-muslim
countries
when he was
contradicted when they said well the
reason that's because is because muslim
countries are very oppressive he said no
i did the controls for that too it
doesn't count
he said i did the controls for that it
says i found that controlling for a
political regime in my statistical
analysis did not change the findings
more muslims equals less homicide
the more muslims there are in a society
the less people get murdered
that is now the fact
it is now a fact and you know it's
common sense actually let me give you
one anecdote malaysia
who here fears for their life when they
walk outside at night in malaysia
at two o'clock in the morning 12 o'clock
some of the brothers are walking around
eating arab food do you feel like you're
gonna get attacked
do you feel any sort if you're in dubai
for instance do you feel like you're
going to get attacked or assaulted
saudi arabia do you feel like you're
let me tell you about chicago
where i grew up
last year 500 people were murdered by
guns alone
500 you don't even hear about five
murders in malaysia
500 people in one city in the united
states were killed by gun violence alone
that's not counting other weapons or
domestic violence that's just murders by
guns
500 people in one city in the united
states
that's more than most of the muslim
countries combined
[Music]
and then they call us violent
you can't walk in chicago at two o'clock
in the morning you will die
i promise you you will die
or you will be mugged and if you're a
woman you will be raped
that is not a joke
you walk in certain places in chicago at
two o'clock in the morning you will not
come back
okay
everyone there owns a gun and at least
two people per day die in chicago from
gang related violence
and some of them are minors
i'm talking 12 year olds 13 year olds
being shot
okay
this is not a joke this happens all the
time in the united states i carry a gun
in the united states
to protect myself i'm not joking
i have a gun not with me right now but
in the u.s i have a firearm i carry it
under my clothes
especially with trump supporters now
with all these white supremacists i have
to carry a gun even more
okay
there's no joke and the sisters the
muslim sisters in the united states are
more likely to be attacked than the
brothers
i have heard of so many cases where a
muslim sister walking down the street in
the middle of the day and a man will
walk up and rip every job off and start
kicking and punching her
that is not a joke
there are places in the u.s that are
perfectly safe if you've been there you
know
but not all places are safe there are
places in the u.s even the police will
not go to
[Music]
okay
another study recently released
in 2016
these these studies are starting to come
out because people are starting to
realize the nature of secular liberal
societies all right
uh the sister's name is uh
[Music]
she wrote about egyptian minorities
uh in uh her research called religious
difference in a secular age okay this is
the name of the research
what she found was that
the more secular that egypt became
the more
violent people were against religious
minorities
you hear that the more secular a nation
became
the more likely the christians and the
baha'is and the other minorities were
attacked
or killed or their buildings were
destroyed
she tried to judge this based on the
standards of the ottoman empire she
found that
less religious persecution occurred
against minorities during the ottoman
empire than it does today
how is this significant
because everyone is saying
that if you have a religious government
or a muslim government or an islamic
government a real uh khilafah ruling
over the muslims all of a sudden
everyone's going to die
all the religious minorities are going
to be killed you know and we're going to
persecute everyone
but this historically is not the case
and research is now finding that secular
regimes are the cause of more religious
persecution
than even the ottoman empire was capable
of i'll give you another example
this is even more important example
what happened to turkey do you have any
turkish individuals in the audience
i'm sure you know your history very well
what happened during the ottoman reforms
who took power
they were called the young turks
they've been referred do they know who
the young turks were okay they were a
secular nationalist group they wanted to
do away with the ottoman empire does
anybody know about the armenian genocide
some people disputed but
there was a significant number of people
who were killed during that time do you
know who perpetuated the armenian
genocide it was not the island empire it
was the young turks
the young turks were the ones who
started the genocide it was not the
ottoman empire but if you go into
history books they say during this time
period it was the ottoman empire that
killed the armenians but they were not
the ones in power
it was the young turks who were in power
this is very simple go to wikipedia
right now look it up on your phone the
young turks were in power during the
armenian genocide not the sultan
it was the secular nationalists they
were the ones killing everyone
not the muslims
these are historical facts this is not
disputable
so what ideology then fuels this
i'm walking around now so
i'm getting i'm getting worked up that's
why okay now i'm getting really
passionate
[Music]
yes
okay
so what sort of ideology is fueling this
well the easy answer is secular
liberalism and why is this the case well
we're hearing the western media that the
more secular you are the more peaceful
you are
the less violent you are
of course common sense states otherwise
i showed you these studies but not only
that but look at western foreign policy
how many muslim nations are invading
everyone else and bombing them into
oblivion
almost zero
how many western countries
are invading other countries and bombing
them into oblivion
almost all of them
okay
how many muslim countries have been
invaded in the past 20 years
how many coups military coups meaning
that they tried to install a dictator
and destroy the society from within
it's happened almost
i think it's less than 30 but almost
near there okay
who can tell me who is more oppressive
morsi
or cece
thank you
who has killed more people the muslim
brotherhood or cece
[Music]
or sisi
any more questions
the more secular government is
especially within the muslim world the
more violent it becomes
the more likely it is to invade its
neighbors
why is this the case
very simple it's the ideology behind
secular liberalism and i'm going to
actually touch on this briefly because
this is not actually what the lecture is
about but i have to give you some
background
what is secular liberalism okay well
first off they'll tell you it's religion
does not rule over the government that's
the first thing they'll say
separation of church and state
but they say something else they say
individual liberties
freedom freedom of thought freedom of
speech
freedom of whatever else you can
conceive of freedom freedom freedom
but these are not values
the liberal west secular liberal west
defines itself in opposition
to what it does not want to be
what i mean by that is this
secular liberalism was created
not in a vacuum but an opposition to
monarchy supported by a religious state
okay they wanted freedom from that
mostly for economic reasons
now what occurred during this time
uh it's only about two or three hundred
years ago
was that they started to define
themselves in contrast in opposition to
their enemies so they said we are free
free from what
from you
we have freedom of speech
as opposed to what as opposed to you
you have freedom of thought
as opposed to what as opposed to you you
understand
we are free from you that's what
liberalism defines itself as we are
liberal
from you
okay the reason that the united states
and europe can say we are free is
because they keep comparing themselves
to other societies
so for instance the new flavor of enemy
of the day
are muslims
so when the secular liberal west defines
itself as being free they're saying we
are free
compared to you
muslims
and what it does it creates an extreme
picture of its enemies
so liberal west will define muslims as
being overly violent
right suppressive of women suppressive
of speech suppressants of thought
okay
as being less
that is how they define
themselves without us the liberal west
would not know who it is
they would not know themselves because
they need an enemy
in order to know who they are
that's why they have an identity crisis
that's why when you hear things like
british values and american values they
can't tell you what they are
they just tell you that we're not like
you
it's exactly what they do every time
they say what's what is secular values
what is british values they say well
it's not afghanistan
well it's not
you know pakistan it's not saudi arabia
that's what they'll say we can our women
can drive
things like this
except saudi arabia now has the largest
women's university in the world
by the way
but feminists will tell you that
so what it does it creates a projection
of itself what it does not want to be
onto its enemies and then it makes an
excuse to destroy them and to impose
itself onto them that's why you have
universal human rights
they're not universal by the way they're
western
when they say human rights they mean
our rights or you
and if you don't like them we're going
to bother you
that is the truth
that is exactly what they do
gaddafi when he was bombed by nato
forces in libya which by the way is the
reason that isis now controls 70 of
libya because nato decided to bomb him
and destroy him and take him out of
power
the reason that gaddafi was bombed was
not because he killed 40 000 people as
they say because they don't really care
if they cared they would have bombed
syria a long time ago
okay
it doesn't do that
right they bombed him because he wanted
to change the currency that's a long
story as
well um
he was bombed they said that we need to
bring human rights to your people
because they need them they have lost
their rights under you
but they didn't agree to that
they never said please come here and
bomb us and give us our human rights
the west imposed itself saying that you
need them because you are too stupid and
you are too ignorant and you are too
below us to understand that you need our
way of life
that is basically the reasons why they
did what they did and they continue to
do what they do
because they believe we are inferior
and that we need their freedom which is
why they're willing to kill half of our
populations to give it to us
so in this way when a muslim is being
imposed by these standards when a muslim
even living in a liberal society
what's going to happen to them
but they are constantly being told that
they are this thing
even if they're the most liberal person
there's only two options for them one
they become apostates
because they can't handle pressure
that's why if you look at liberal
societies especially in muslim societies
that are becoming more liberal
rates of apostasy go up
dramatically
the more liberal society becomes the
more likely muslims
the apostasy rates are now raising in
malaysia so that may give you a clue as
to what's going on with your politics
just a hint
bangladesh apostasy rates are
skyrocketing what happens when a muslim
is experiencing this in a liberal
society he's told to do one of two
things either become less muslim
or no are not muslim at all to the point
where he becomes a liberal or he wants
to reform his time
okay
or
he becomes the projection that the west
tells him that he is
you understand
he becomes exactly the image that the
west wants him to be
because he doesn't know anything else
that is why a lot of these young boys
men
are joining isis
coming from cocaine addictions
and then jumping straight into
devotion to allah
because they're not actually devout they
are simply fulfilling
what the west is projecting for them
they're doing exactly they are liberals
these young men who are joining us not
only do they not practice but they are
liberals because they're fulfilling
the identity of the west by becoming its
greatest enemy
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
okay
now
what has this created in the muslim
world
it has created the rise of two extremes
this is where we're going to get even
more interested
now we're going to talk about
contemporary events
the syrian revolution and the rise of
isis
the mortgage or the reformers as they
like to call themselves now
have become
a majority within many of these
societies as nationalists
okay as non-practicing muslims and their
counter opposite because these are the
two greatest enemies
among the um
among the what he called the heretics
within islam
and they have also created the floodage
okay
they have created
the most extreme version
of our interpretation of islam that is
all that is that has existed within our
history
so before we get into the footage i want
to speak about these reformers and i
want to talk about the syrian conflict
and i want to make a disclaimer
i apologize beforehand about what i'm
going to say
okay because i know there's a lot of
passionate individuals
a lot of passionate individuals
there's a lot of passionate individuals
in here especially syrians
who
want assad out of power okay i want him
out of power too i want you to
understand that before i say anything
all right
but i want to give you a brief look at
what happened first
in 2011
when the uns the unrest began the
protest and assad was going around
killing
hundreds of people etc
at the end of that year
10 000 people were killed
not just civilians but also soldiers 10
000 okay
when the revolution went into full swing
what i mean is when the rebels finally
came together and started to fight back
in a military fashion okay
that number rose dramatically
now you have half a million people are
dead
to this day
and it is rising
assad is still in power
more groups have entered syria
more groups have taken power in syria
isis has taken almost half of syria
i need to ask you a serious question for
those of you who are still
backing this revolution was it worth it
i know that's a very
hard
question that i've given you but i'm
asking you again
half a million people are dead
in 2011 it was 10 000
half a million
are dead and still rising
assad is still in power
he's gaining land again
he's fighting back
okay he's not going to lose it anytime
soon
all right
hezbollah is now inside
isis is inside a new front is inside we
have various factions within the syrian
rebel groups that are fighting each
other and killing each other more
civilians are leaving refugees are
constantly being poured into into into
europe now people are losing their homes
their lives
was it worth it
that is a question i think that we need
to seriously ask ourselves
and
i want to be
to be blunt here as well i do not
support assad at all however i support
our traditional scholars with respect to
rebellion
in respect to their understanding of
thank you very much is this a
ten more minutes wow
it's not much time actually i hope we
can extend it a little bit a lot more to
say
so 10 000 people were killed in 2011 50
000 in 2012 100 000 by 2013
now between 250 to 500 000 i'd say it's
half a million
many of the fsa the
free syrian army have defected and gone
to isis
many of them have defected and gone to
isis
now saudi arabia is getting involved
russia has already been involved they
said they're leaving but they're not
they're still there
the united states is involved every
country this is world war iii everyone
is involved
because we want to get rid of one guy
now am i saying he was right
he's a good person no he's horrible he
deserves
death
for what he has done
he deserves it but our scholars were
very
they're very wise about this
they're they said that it's legitimate
to take out a ruler if he's
for instance he's a catheter or if he's
uh he's unjust to his people it's
legitimate however
they said that there are limitations to
that as well for instance and this is
the most important point
uh they quote uh they mentioned this
uh where
the prophet saws said a muslim must not
humiliate himself it was asked of him
how does a muslim humiliate himself and
the prophet saws responded and said by
exposing himself to an affliction that
he is not able to bear
the prophet doesn't respond and said by
exposing himself to an affliction that
he cannot bear
meaning if you know
if you let your passions run and you
think and you know you're going up
against a superior force and you know by
doing so you're going to destroy your
entire society and everyone in it
is this the wisest decision to make
remember 10 000 people it's horrible 10
000 people died in 2011.
it is five hundred thousand
five hundred thousand we can't even
comprehend that many people did
and the amount of refugees millions
millions how can you comprehend that
you